so basically i just try and set up good
systems and then the individual
decisions aren't that don't don't matter
that much
because i think our ability to make
individual decisions is actually not
great so for example as an investor i
would rather invest i would rather
my system is i want to see 10 000
companies and i want to pick
500 that have a shot of being huge and
then i want the option to double down on
the five winners
i don't want to just look at 100
companies and pick 10 that i think are
winners and go all in on those right
because i don't think i have that
capability and i think there's a lot of
exposed factor reasoning and uh
and uh sort of origin stories that
people make up about why they were
successful
but the real separation here is you look
at which people are consistently
successful especially in silicon valley
there are lots of one-hit wonders but
how many people consistently seem to do
something interesting uh build something
interesting make money and do something
new